- [Instructor] So let's play
a game of Spot the Difference.
Now, if you were asked
to spot the difference
between these two pictures,
you'd probably laugh and
say, "That's too easy."
Because it's obvious that this
picture of a lion on the left
is nowhere close to
looking like the picture
of a green fern plant on the right.
What's more, a lion and a fern
not only look completely different,
they also function differently.
But what if I told you that
if we zoomed in really close
and compared the lion's
cells with the fern's cells,
they'd actually share many similarities?
An animal cell and a plant cell
have several common features
as well as a few key differences.
In this video, we're going
to spot the similarities
and the differences between
the two types of cells,
and talk about their
functions inside the cells.
So, first off, let's take
a look at some cell models.
Here on the left is an animal cell,
and on the right is a plant cell.
First, let's try and identify the things
that both animal and plant
cells share in common.
If you recall, both animal and plant cells
have a cell membrane,
which acts like a gate
to control what enters
and leaves the cell.
Animal cells and plant cells
also have this jelly-like
substance called the cytosol,
which contains organelles
or small compartments
with specific functions inside the cell.
Animal and plant cells share
several common organelles,
two of which include the
nucleus and the mitochondria.
The nucleus within each cell type
serves as an information database
to store the cell's genes,
while the mitochondria act as
factories to break down sugars
and release energy that the cells can use.
So now that we've identified some features
found in both kinds of cells,
let's look closer to spot
the fundamental differences
between animal and plant cells.
As you can see in this diagram,
plant cells have an
additional layer of material
that surrounds the cell membrane.
This is called a cell wall,
which makes the plant cell
more structured and stiff.
Think of a celery stalk
compared to a raw piece
of chicken or fish.
The animal muscle tissue is floppy
while the celery stalk is firm.
That's cell walls in action.
Also, plant cells have
these special organelles
called chloroplasts, which
are what give plants,
like the fern we saw, their green color.
Chloroplasts are the
site of photosynthesis,
which is how plants make their own food
in the form of sugars.
If the word sugar rings a
bell, you're on the right track
because I mentioned
earlier that mitochondria
are responsible for breaking down sugars.
In plant cells, chloroplasts
and mitochondria
are like good buddies that help each other
and work together.
Chloroplasts make sugars
through photosynthesis
and mitochondria convert
the sugars into energy
that, ultimately, the plant can use.
Both cell walls and chloroplasts
are found in plant cells
but not animal cells, such
as the ones in you and me.
And luckily for you and me,
this means we aren't green.
In summary, we just identified
several similarities
and differences in our comparison
of animal and plant cells.
While both cell types
have a cell membrane,
cytosol, a nucleus, and mitochondria,
plant cells have a cell wall
that makes them stiff and rigid,
think about celery stalks,
and they have chloroplasts,
which makes sugars and give
plants their green color.
All of these are just a handful
of the similarities and differences
between plant and animal cells.
As you go forward in your biology journey,
you'll probably learn about a lot more.
But the differences that we've covered
are a big part of what
makes plant and animal cells
so distinct and unique from each other.
These differences are why
we don't see green lions
that photosynthesize using chloroplasts
or floppy raw veggies with cell
membranes but no cell walls.
- Now I hope that you
have a clear understanding
of the different cell parts in
both animal and plant cells,
and that spotting the
differences between the two
will be easy breezy.